[music]
>> Hello, a very good afternoon everyone.
It's really amazing to see such a good
audience here after a late afternoon. I
hope everyone is feeling refreshed
because I can assure you that this panel
is going to bring some of the most
insightful sharing in terms of how we
can bridge the gap between the factory
deployment, between the technology that
we see in the market, and bridging them,
bringing them from pilots to actual
deployments, right? So, my name is Edwin
Yap. I'm the founder of 6D Robot, and
I'm pleased to be moderating today's
discussion. We have a great panel with
us today. We have um
Sviatoslav from Bright Machines, If
Alberts Stromberg from Roboto AI,
Brennan Pierce from Kinema Robotics, and
Vincent Parton from Key Maker. So, the
topic today is very practical, right?
Robotics and physical AI advancing very
quickly. But, the real challenge is no
longer how do we make something that's
impressive.
We're looking at the harder question,
which is bringing the technology from
real just demo into real factories and
making them reliable, integrating them
into existing workflow, proving the ROI,
and scaling beyond the pilot. So, to
start, I'll ask each of the panelists to
introduce himself, and also tell us
about what is the biggest gap that you
see right now in the market between
pilot and real factory deployment. So,
if you can just start with Sviatoslav by
introducing yourself, please.
>> Thank you.
It's great to be here. Thanks Edwin for
moderating.
So, my name is Sviatoslav. I'm the CEO
of Bright Machines. Maybe quickly, what
we do at Bright Machines, we are
building
the factories with a new approach with
robotics and AI first, and we brought
those factories to assemble complex
electronics. We focus 100% on what we
call data center infrastructure, so you
can think about compute, all the servers
and racks that go to data centers. We
assemble them with robots powered by
AI-enabled software and data. And just
to understand how we operate in this
like this segment of the market
operates, I think the big gap to to the
point of the panel is the operations
ownership. Um as you know, as you might
know in electronics, there are like
designers of the product that are OEMs,
and there are like manufacturers that
are usually called CMs, contract
manufacturers, and historically uh most
of the manufacturing has been centered
in China, and um
design somewhere in California, like if
you think about Apple. Um and then, you
know, some other companies trying to
provide solutions like robots and
software to deploy on those floors, and
because of that triangle actually, it
it's kind of a bottleneck to uh fast
deployments and evolvement of robotics
in the industry. And we can deep dive
into this later.
Okay, thank you. Yeah, Yves, please.
>> Yes, hello everyone. Um super excited to
be here. My name is Yves. I'm the CTO
and co-founder of Robot AI,
and we're building a data analytics
platform for robotics data. So, if
you're collecting a lot of data, you
know, in a manufacturing context,
drones, self-driving cars, you need to
analyze all of that data. You need to be
able to search through it, you could
curate it, and then we're building a
SaaS platform to help with that. And um
maybe some of the biggest gaps that
we're currently seeing, you know, I
think we see a lot of pilots that are
failing because um
ultimately, they don't really
achieve the up time and reliability that
are required for um to operate at scale.
Um and we see a big part of that is kind
of that there's not enough data
available, and I think in two respects.
On the one side,
there's not enough data to really train
these models for like the specific
applications and make sure they're
reliable, but there's also not enough
operational data to really prove to the
executive sponsors that um you know, the
system is ready for scaling up. So,
really kind of more data, but the right
data. I think that's a big bottleneck
right now in the whole industry.
>> Right, very interesting. I think
definitely we've been seeing a lot of
mentions about data, whether in every
panel or even sharing by most of the
keynotes that we see today. Um Renat,
please.
>> Hello, nice to meet you. So, I'm here
for CEO of Neocities, but also I founded
multiple other robot companies. I can
say um historically, if you think of the
AMR um robots, they're they're basically
out there. My previous companies shipped
tens of thousands of them, so it's
pretty easy. I think if we take this
more the the future humanoid-esque
AI, I think we'll get into better
discussion about how hard it is to bring
hardware into the real world. I could
just say
not only software, but generally it's a
scaling problem. If you're just a pure
software SaaS company, you can go out
and start
100 500 pilots to really out who wants
your product. When a robot costs 50,000
per robot, you can't you can only go and
do like 20 pilots realistically, and you
just got to pray and your whole startup
you know, it's based on will one of
those companies want that robot? And
then the other aspects is you keep on
wanting to update the hardware and now
you got it like in Canisius my company
like 10 robots into the field. Now you
have to keep on trying to update them.
They all get out of sync. They're all
different generations. And yeah, this is
the hard part about the the valley of
death before you go into mass
production.
>> All right, Brennan is definitely the
veteran of robotic startups. I was
reading about your recent exit to Bear
Robotics. Maybe you can share a bit
about that later as well.
>> What was that last three?
>> Sorry, what
>> Oh, yeah. So, I sold my company 2 weeks
ago to my previous company. I like to
say do it Elon Musk. And generally that
is
it shows how hard even as a I don't want
to brag, but you know, I've done
multiple robot startups. And you show
it's it's really quite hard to get out
there, raise money, and actually scale.
So, it was a quite natural fit to sell
it to my previous company. They already
have like 150 sales people. They have
factory set up in in Asia. They have all
the infrastructure we needed to scale
that we would have to try and compete
ourselves. And at the moment,
you know, there's about 200 other
startups basically trying to do the same
thing. So, it's quite hard to stand out.
>> All right, thank you. Is that
>> Yes, well, Vincent and I'm very happy to
be here as well.
10 years ago we started Kitemaker here
actually in Station F. We were one of
the first startup incubated here.
10 years later, 300 engineers based in
Paris, building robots, industrializing
robots for third party. So, I'm very
happy to be sitting next to previous
customer. And I can see some other
customer in the room here. So, um to us
industrialization of hardware is
definitely the key right now when we
speak about the gap between indeed
prototype and factory. Industrialization
is a huge step. That's the value of
this. And before that indeed what Brent
was saying, design phase of a version is
very important. But as the
Moore's curve is accelerating, people
are actually, you know, developing
product faster and more and more and you
want more feature because you want to
have the latest technology inside and
that kills everything. So, to us the
biggest challenge is how to read the
future. Nothing will be basically
customer ready within the next year or
so, 18 months eventually. But still, you
will have to deliver something to
customer that works and works at scale.
And in the meantime, we know that, you
know, electronics is an industry that is
uh fairly outsourced. So, that means
that you need to manage dependencies
with CM, with third party, with stake
providers. And thus managing all that is
very hard.
>> Yeah, very interesting perspective on
managing different stakeholders,
especially when different industries
typically have different setup in terms
of the structure of their teams. So, the
next question I'm going to I'm going to
actually come back to a CBET. So, my
machine talks about intelligent
manufacturing, right? So, how different
is it, you know, comparing intelligent
manufacturing to conventional
traditional manufacturing? Is Is it just
as simple as adding an AI element or do
you have other thoughts?
>> Not really. Um but maybe yes, one step
back historically
as rightfully mentioned, human
manufacturing depends a lot depended a
lot on
contract manufacturers, mostly by the
way around Asia. China first and then
for some components in Taiwan. Um and
recently in Philippines and Thailand. Um
but the problem is the way they solve
the problem uh when they get um uh some
inputs from OEMs or designers is like to
put people first and try to solve it
with the flexibility of humans. Um in
China, if you go to Shenzhen, there are
like factories that employ
100,000 people on a given day um for for
those reasons. The way we approach it is
from different angle. First, we start
with design. One of the biggest problems
is connecting design and manufacturing
in advance before you start production
uh because then you can optimize for uh
robotics and automation. Then we use
robotics and software for manufacturing,
then we use um software to collect the
data that can drive further efficiencies
and can improve your next generation
designs because you already know from
your line how it was built, where the
failures came from. It could be better
supply chain and better components or it
could be different than the worm tools,
could be different sequence of uh
operations and so on and so forth. But
the way the way we look at our which
that we call a bright factory, we put
robotics and software first, and also
AI-powered design. And when you put all
this together and then you use this data
in the future for
future improvements, that's how you
drive a different approach to
manufacturing versus what existed uh for
50-plus years around China and Asian
regions.
>> Right. It's It's great that you
mentioned about data and especially uh
that brings me to the next question uh
to to Eef specifically. So, you
mentioned that one of the biggest gap
you see today is with data. So, what do
you think is missing today in terms of
the infrastructure along, you know,
trying to build a robotics data and
filling that gap of uh you know,
bridging between the vision to to what
we are now?
>> I think what we're seeing is like a kind
of an interesting thing is like we call
it like a data paradox in robotics where
on the one side you have too much
robotics data. So, we see companies
scaling up, they have bigger fleets,
more manufacturing robot, they generate
a ton of data, the data's multimodal,
you know, can be point clouds,
image data, time series data. You can
amass terabytes just in a couple of
minutes. And these companies actually
just don't have the tools to automate
the inspection of all of the data.
What's happening is that a lot of edge
cases are slipping through.
They end up hitting, you know,
customers. So, that's kind of one part
of the data problem. And then the other
part of the data problem, that's what
we're hearing a lot today about is that
there's not enough like high-quality
data to train these models and kind of
build, you know, generalizable models.
And what we think, kind of, you know, to
solve both of these issues, you need
better data infrastructure that really
helps you to
search through all of the data,
structure data, and find kind of the the
events and and patterns in all these
data sets, which are actually going to
make a difference. So, it's really like,
um, yeah, you need a data analytics
engine to to deal with the sheer size of
this robotics data. And that's a lesson
that we've also learned from the AV
community, as well.
>> All right, data paradox is definitely a
very interesting term that we hear today
because a lot of people have been
talking about data collection. So, not
many are actually talking about the
engine that powers how to collect the
data, annotate the data, and make making
the data actually useful for all the all
the AI models, right? So, the next
question I have for Brendan is, you
know, after having so many exits and
getting closer to Elon Musk in his net
worth,
definitely more than any of us here
today. So, how do you decide which
factory or warehouse tasks are more
suitable
for automation?
>> That's a That's a great question. So, at
the moment,
um, we're like inundated with inbound
from customers that say, you know, we
need humanoids. I think this is
like the cryptocurrency or let's say
it's the blockchain
uh of like couple of years ago. So, the
CEOs are like, we need humanoids in our
factory and warehouse. So, we get like
inundated. We normally have like this
gating factor where we chat to them,
they send us videos. We can actually
tell them if it's realistic, if it's
not, how serious they are, what what
other aspects that goes into it before
you decide to take on these customers.
At the [snorts] moment, very boring,
repetitive tasks and try to like, um,
cluster them so you You solve one
customer's problem and sell it to a lot
of others. For us, it's just like
driving around picking up totes, doing
assembly lines. I do think with the data
paradox, I think it's quite amusing.
It
Historically, you couldn't do a lot of
these tasks cuz you would need a lot of
engineers to hand code all the tasks.
But we're finding at the moment most of
the time with the amount of data you
need to collect, you could probably
actually just hand code all a lot of
these tasks with just classical
controllers. So, it's a chicken and the
egg problem. It's It's well as we're
chatting about how to ramp up, it's also
you need like
hundreds and hundreds of hours of like
training data sets. And if it goes out
of distribution, it doesn't work. How to
get it to 100%? It's still like a very
hard task, I think, to actually see
these as real robots doing real tasks.
We We semi cheat now. So, not only do
you collect the data and get your models
to about 95% then you can either then
use Claude and hand code monitoring
systems using classical controllers
using like YOLO, SAM, and things like
that to be like, "All right, if it's If
this scenario happens, reset it and do
all these things that you hand You have
to basically hand tune it to actually
work and deploy these foundational
models at a customer site." Which goes
back to the fact that you could have
just done this with classical
controllers for a lot of these tasks.
But that's obviously a dead end and why
we're trying to get better at getting
foundational models to to run. And I
think the last point as well why you
haven't seen this is Customers want
these robots to work fast, efficient at
100%. We just finished a what we thought
was a
successful pilot with a customer, but
we're about half the speed of a human.
And our robots are half the cost of a
human, so it sort of works out. But you
know,
we're they're very happy like we
actually have a robot working 100% can
do a shift for 8 hours. All our
engineers like, "This is bleeding edge
technology." And you see the CEO and the
executives just looking like, "So,
when's he going to get faster?"
>> Right. But that's only the idea is, you
know, you're starting at 50% now, but
there's a potential for you to get get
to 60, 70, or even closer even
surpassing the speed of a speed, right?
>> Correct.
>> Right. So, okay, so that brings me to
the next question. When we are at that,
you know, utopian world where all the
boring and repetitive tasks are being
done by robots, right? That means
scaling the robots from I think last
year the humanoid robots production was
close to about 15,000 units. So, let's
say if we get to that vision of millions
of robots being produced, how do you
think that uh people are not really
noticing right now from getting from
right now to to that utopian that we're
talking about?
>> So, first of all, the question and, you
know, um just answering to Ren
um are these factories
uh really needs humanoids at the end of
the day, you know, most of these
repetitive tasks at the end of the day
don't need uh what we call a generalist
platform, okay, general purpose
robotics. They just need a task to be
done. And in general, I think this is
where we confuse
most of the thing. The robot is not the
product, the system is the product, the
solution is the product. And within the
product, basically 30% is the hardware,
but 70% is about integration, it's about
data management, maintenance, and
servicing the end customer. And all that
basically is not ready. It's not ready.
Why? Because the traditional system
integrator for robotics are working with
very fixed environment, very repetitive,
and reliable uh task. It's not in a
real-world environment where where it
comes to a smart data, smart management,
physical AI, we want everything to be
seamless for everybody.
So, uh to me there is a huge gap between
where we are today and what the market
needs in term of of pure automation. And
when we look what's happening in China,
50 hardware companies are going IPO this
year. They fight for it. 50 at once
going IPO. So, I think there would be a
huge market consolidation. Thanks to
China, we have a supply chain that's
here working with reliable components,
but at the end of the day the customer
end specification isn't ready. So, I
think it's time for all of us basically
to learn, and the first thing to learn,
as Brandon said is how to run POC, how
to run pilot phases with customer
success, how to service customer well in
that kind of environment, how to engage
discussion with the CEO where it does
not expect you to deliver the throughput
but just understand that you will help
him learn basically how to use
technology in the same way that he's
just learning how to use cloud because
cloud in 2 years from now is going to be
completely different. So at the time
being it's like how do we make this
entire economy sustaining enough
with well managed funds so that we just
don't do all the same and we just come
with a professional offer at once once
the market is ready and when we
until then only then sorry we can start
to fight with union that are going to
replace workers.
>> All right, definitely the acceptance of
I think Brandon you have
>> I was going to say when you said how do
you get your customers
what Vince was saying is if a customer
says what is your picks per hour you
know it's not a customer that's going to
be happy with humanoid at
the current rate.
>> Yeah, cuz earlier we we also talked
about stakeholders management, right? So
the people who ordered the humanoid and
often not a users of the humanoids,
right? They're not replacing the task
that being done by that person that
particular person. So so a lot of this
really comes down to the acceptance
level of the society in terms of do we
really want to get them to replace us so
that you know we we do nothing and
there's definitely a lot of discussion
that revolving around how do we make
people accept automation, accept
robotics even more. So I think it's
interesting that you mentioned about the
supply chain from China and do you think
that there is a possibility for them to
converge in terms of supply chain just
like how it happened with EV cars, just
like how it happened with mobile phones
where there only a few screen makers
now, there only a few and you know
microphone makers and battery makers and
so on.
>> At the end of the day everything comes
from the customer request, okay? So if
you go to China and you go eat you but
basically you know what they are doing
right now. They are throwing this little
Wukong robot in every house because it's
a robot for children and these guys
basically in 5-10 years they will very
welcome robots because they will be they
will have been playing with it for a
while, right? And the supply chain at
the end will follow. At the time being,
you know, I see like a word that is in
two parts, China on one side, US on the
other side, but we all know it's not
true.
Uh because you know, there is a lot of
money and technology flowing from one to
the other. And what are we doing in
Europe? Okay, when will we get our first
GPU ready? When will we get uh ST, uh
you know, bring a platform that's able
to compete against Nvidia? We're having
in France and just recently our first uh
EV car factory for batteries, so that's
good. Uh and so on and so on. So, it's
very difficult to say if everything will
convert, but I do think that at the end
of the once every people from its
personal use will start to welcome
automation, everything will follow.
>> All right, definitely can't wait for
that day to come. So, the next question
brings me back to Nvidia. So, Bright
Machines is focused on building the
infrastructure that powers AI, uh
including data centers, AI hardware. So,
how is this AI infrastructure boom that
we're seeing around that is actually
changing the urgency and the scale and
even the complexity of this game now?
>> Actually in a really positive way. Um
so, we are 8 years old now and you know,
we started as a company we built all
different types of electronics from like
smoke detectors to drills to coffee
machines like Nespresso.
Um but when you build units that are
like 90 or 80 dollars per unit and
everybody cares about units per hour and
like not that much yield because it's
like a cheap units, the motivation to
invest in innovation and explore new
methods was not as high.
Around 4 years ago we made the bet on
data centers, 3 and a half maybe. Um and
then
a little bit less than 4 years ago
ChatGPT moment happened and maybe half a
year afterwards every market in the
world started looking at how we build AI
infrastructures to support our needs for
AI development and the models. And then
they realized that each server compute
node that we build can go up to like
350,000 dollars of components in it.
Uh the cost of mistake is really high.
If you break a GPU or like a
motherboard, uh if you break a GPU it's
like 30K, if you break a motherboard
it's like I don't know 10 15K. And then
the tension is higher and the desire for
automation and actually excluding people
from the process loop is is really high.
And so right now we see a lot of um
interest in that and that's why we work
with like leading companies that build
out AI infrastructure and build
um
a lot of servers and and racks for them
uh with robots first and human second.
By the way, just maybe quickly to follow
up on the idea of like, you know,
creating jobs versus
taking robots and reducing the jobs. Our
model is pretty cool because we take
robots but we still create jobs because
as I mentioned, the complexity of the
design is still so far from 100%
automation, you still need humans in the
loop. Uh both for assembly but also
engineers for like, you know, services
and other things. So actually that makes
the whole use case of deploying
automation in the markets where you
don't have enough labor um in terms of
skill and also like the scale of that
labor. Like you take Germany, the US,
UK, I don't know, France maybe um is
actually a really good use case. Um and
that that would resonate with both
workers and the companies who want to
put um innovation into operations.
>> All right, very interesting that
actually putting more people human in
the loop and um basically training
people so that you you know, we we can
unlock our hands in the future. And um
the next question is for you um a lot of
companies talk about data flywheels,
right? Getting starting early so you get
more data to improve the model and from
there you deploy more robots that gets
you even more data. So what does a real
data flywheel look like in production,
not just in a pitch deck?
>> Yeah, I think it's it's a very good
question. I think what we see in reality
is that kind of like most companies
don't really have a data flywheel. They
have an issue in, you know, in in in
operations. They have to kind of
manually pull these log files, analyze
them, visualize them and so
I think what a real data flywheel looks
like you want to kind of automate as
much as possible of the whole analytics
process of your data pipeline. And so
that starts with automatically getting
the data off your vehicle, your
production lines,
being smart about what data you get from
your production lines.
Um then you want to index your data, you
want to make it searchable, and then
enrich it so you can start to run
queries against your data.
Um
and then on top of it you want to have
like automated ways to triage your data
sets. Like if something goes wrong, why
did it go wrong? Who should look at it?
Should the perception team look at it?
Should the navigation team look at it?
Where you start to kind of automate a
lot of of that analysis. And I think
that's kind of where you're getting to
really kind of uh a true data flywheel,
which is a bit different than kind of
the classic training data flywheel.
More robots, more data equals better
uh models, more robots, which is good
for pitch decks, but I think in reality
it's it's it's more nuanced than that.
>> Right. So so do you see like a trend of
actually having and seeing more data
engineers in factories right now?
Because of this shift?
>> Yeah, and I I think in general I think
what the industry kind of needs is maybe
not so much more models or better
hardware. It's it's more like I think
something like a devops process for, you
know, integration. And so it's not just
a wall of integration. Okay, you have
all your integrators, they go there,
they do the pilot, and then hand it off.
It's more like you need to have like
yeah, site reliability engineers forward
deployed, really kind of tuning these
models, making sure we get the right
data. I think that's kind of the where
the industry has the biggest bottleneck
right now. And I think we could see way
more actually applications deployed with
today's hardware and technology if we
have more of that kind of devops culture
in robotics as well.
>> Right. Speaking of hardware, um
I think Brennan would be in the best
position to answer this question. So
what do you think is the danger of over
designing robots for science fiction,
you know, looking exactly like a human
instead of actually building something
that solves the pain point of the
customers?
>> Money. So the problem in robotics is
it's it is competing with China.
It goes be time. Um
At Bear Robotics, you know, we shipped
like 15, 20, maybe even 25,000 robots
now. But we're probably still like 20%
more expensive than Pudu and we build
them in the same factory. So it's just
unfortunately with China, they they have
an unfair advantage or their government
subsidizes them.
And then the big problem is CTO CFOs,
they will look at the cost and it all
comes down to that. They'll just be like
no matter how sexy your pilot is, they
will look at two things. What does it
cost currently? What does it cost for
your competitors? So at Bear, you know,
you even start chatting about
can you afford to put LEDs in it? Cuz
when you're shipping that many, you're
just like, well, you put an LED the size
of screen, it's $50 here, $50 there.
You're saying like you do that over
10,000 a year, you're like that's half a
million, that's half a million profit
margin. Or if you're robotics, [snorts]
you're lucky to have a profit margin.
And then I think realistically, it's
getting to the point where hardware in
the robots is now a sunk cost and you
never make money in robotics. You have
to look at making your money back on the
WMS layer, on the warehouse, on the OS
layer or some other way where you're
just like, here is the robots, we're
going to lose a bit of money on it, but
if we deploy like 20 to 100 to 200 in
your factory, we'll also do X, Y, and Z
and you make the money there cuz it's
such a cutthroat industry.
And it's it's just quite hard to compete
in pure robot world.
>> It's most likely going to
sort of like evolve into how we're
getting our cell phones now, right? So
basically the phones are free, you're
just paying for subscription.
>> Exactly.
>> same case as robotics as well.
>> It's I think it's also like the same as
any electronics. It's like a cutthroat
industry. You look at washing machines
and things like that where there's not
many players cuz there's not many profit
margins in there. Anything else you get
to like a 5% profit margin and
for a dishwasher, you don't need a room
of 100 AI engineers that competing with
Google or something for salary and all
the rest of the engineers for the cost
cost factors that goes into it.
>> Right. Okay, thanks so much for sharing.
So, uh Vincent, um
what separates a good prototype as we're
talking about, you know, manufacturing,
right? What separates a good prototype
from something that is truly ready for
manufacturing?
>> So, I think it all comes to a very
specific question. You know, engineering
team will say a prototype, yes, that's
work.
But, something that is scalable and
manufacturable needs to be done a
thousand time by someone that has not
designed it. Okay? And to come to that
stage, basically, that means first of
all,
we need to make sure
that it's uh the end targeting operator
that is assembling the robot himself to
understand if your design is reliable.
Okay? Um a good prototype will be
something that help you raise money.
Okay? A good workable product will help
you, basically, make money out of the
blue. And that's the entire difference.
Um and to come to one point to the
other, it's really a transition phase
stage matter. Okay? And the biggest
mistake that we have seen so many time
in so many company is using your R&D
engineer to do this industrialization.
Okay? And the main point, again, coming
to China is that we have outsourced so
much of our design and innovation to
China that we have very very few
engineers that know, basically, how to
industrialize a product, make it
productable, and also just it's a handle
the pace of industrialization. Okay?
Because a plastic needs time to freeze.
Uh you need time for long lead time
components and everything. And this is
definitely not the same team to be able
to handle everything. Okay? So,
cadencing, planning, everything is key,
uh basically, to to come to a good
working prototype and something that is
manufacturable.
>> All right, thank you so much for trying.
So, this um the next question is going
to be a little bit cross-panel and I'd
like, you know, any panelists to jump in
as you like. So, do you think
manufacturers are focused just too much
on the ROI, just too much on the
costing, and they're ignoring
some important factors such as quality,
reliability, or even safety?
>> Yeah, I mean, we are not here, and I
know that the next panel is going to be
about cybersecurity and safety, and
that's going to be a very interesting
point because this is something that we
have seen from customer risk request
just very frequently because a year ago
everybody was about like, "Okay, I want
a robot. Whatever is inside, I don't
care, okay? And I will go see marking,
whatever certification that is there
because people will sell pilot." But now
people are starting to be serious about
it, and they want a robot that's safe,
okay? But at the time being, we have
safe component, okay? We don't have safe
system, okay? Um so, um this uh entire
question is is very important. I do
think that supply chain, process,
factories, component are there, okay?
But how to execute well the process to
reach your market is not there just
because we don't know where the market
is.
>> And also at um
connected multiple startups in the
robotics space, I think a classic thing
that I've done myself before is uh you
get a robot, you you're happy with it,
and then you suddenly go to mass
manufacturing or go to big clients, and
they're saying like, "Have you got all
these ISO standards? Have you got all
this other certification?" You're like,
"No, I wrote it in ROS with Python, and
I got a cheap Chinese lidar." And then
all of these things then uh we worked
with Vincent and Kick May before at Bear
when we were productionizing.
Unfortunately, you're like, "I got this
really good lidar. We've We've We've
been using it for about 2 years, and it
works." Then you suddenly go, "It's not
[snorts] acceptable. You now need to buy
a SICK lidar that's four times the cost.
Um and you need all these
certifications, and now you also need an
MCU and all these other things that when
you get a load of PhD or clever uh
engineers to build the system that they
suddenly forget that you there's this
whole engineering,
you know, the paradigm of safety
certification, how can you prove its
safety? It's even down to
brakes on the robot and all these other
things that you generally forget about
when you're when you're trying to do a
startup and get something shipped.
>> Right, definitely. So, uh as I try to
wrap up this session, I'd like the
panelists to actually give um your
opinion on what is that one myth about
factory robotics deployment that you
would like to correct, starting from
Sibi.
>> I know, I think the the main myth is
like most of the videos that you look at
uh and they say like this is the
deployment is mostly in the labs and
when you get to the real production,
it's much more complex and complicated.
Um but to be fair, I think like this
general-purpose stuff is like maybe
nascent. The other camp that we are part
of like use case-based applications is
more advanced and we can see actually
finally how much faster and more
flexible we became in the recent years
um moving away from the lab to real
production and being able to produce,
you know, hundreds of thousands of um
units from those robots. You were the
yield and and throughput. But again,
when I see many of the videos, it's a
little bit funny because I know that
most of them are lab environment and
hopefully we're going to get to real
production really soon with that
technology, but it's going to take
years.
>> I'm starting to see some now.
All right, if
>> Yeah, I think maybe building on top of
that, I think one myth that we're
hearing a lot is just get more data and
it will solve all the problems and I
think, you know, sometimes I get emails,
I'm selling you $500 of robotics data,
do you want to buy it? You know, I've no
idea where it comes from and I think
what we see is, you know, yes, more data
can help, but you need to be very
strict about quality
um and where it comes from and and that
can really move the needle and too much
data is also a problem as well. Um so,
yeah.
>> Yeah, so I was just talking to, you
know, one of the SBDs outside. So, I was
asking them how is it? And then and then
he just told me like more than 10 people
have come up to me and said they want to
sell me data.
>> Just today, some people approached me,
they want to buy some data and I like
what what data?
>> There's a lot of people that are like
we're collecting data and I like I don't
know what data we need. Um great answer
there. I would just say
the one thing that surprised me over the
last couple years is we talk about
humanoid AI in this. I've gone to big
companies that have like 500
factories or warehouses and you walk
around and you don't see one robot. You
just see hundreds and hundreds of
people. So you don't even need to get
the cool AI or the humanoid robotics.
You look at it and be like, "Have you
ever heard of something called an AMR?"
You know, to me it's like you can buy
300 AMRs and instantly get ROI and they
and they decide to skip all of that and
then talk to humanoid companies which
always makes me chuckle.
>> All right. That's for the lot of these,
isn't it?
>> All right. I will conclude with a
sentence proposed by our best friend
Claude.
And to conclude that panel basically say
physical AI is the headline but
deployment will be the story.
>> So okay.
>> I should have done that.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. And with that I'd like to
wrap up the panel. Thank you so much for
your time today.
>> [applause]